semaine de rentrée scolaire un peu
partout en france y compris dans les
endroits les plus reculés que ma l'île
d'aix par exemple le moins de 200
habitants répartis sur les trois
kilomètres de long de l'ill avec au
centre une classe unique de 12 élèves
françois privat si les prix tel poids
kilomètres de terre se découpe sur
l'horizon une île l'île d'aix près de la
rochelle le bateau pour 20 minutes de
traversée et tout au bout de la rue
principale du village l'école et sa
classe unique
douze élèves âgés de 2 à 10 on fait des
enfants entièrement présents sur l'île
une seule école et donc aucune
possibilité de regroupement pédagogique
alors il faut faire cohabiter des élèves
d'âge différent dans la classe on
organise l'espace avec un coin pour les
pretty un lieu où l'on travaille un
autre pour la lecture
la richesse et la variété de
l'environnement aux fautes aussi des
possibilités d'enseignement inédite à la
ville parce que elle a connecté via
l'elysée
installé sur l'île depuis deux ans
l'institutrice nathalie richard ne
regrette pas ce qu'elle appelle un choix
de vie en revanche l'insularité fait
surgir des difficultés insoupçonnable
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez offrir en
plus à vos élèves
est ce que les autres ont un cycle de
piscine
une visite régulière dans une grande
médiathèque quelques séances de théâtre
c'est la photo d'une classe unique sur
unique qu'il est aussi